cruzan el río arauca en balsa huyen de
una serie de operaciones militares en
venezuela por parte del ejército el
desplazamiento masivo de venezolanos
comenzó el 21 de marzo luego de que
tropas militares bolivarianas lanzarán
una ofensiva aérea y terrestre contra
grupos armados ilegales en el municipio
de la victoria ubicada en el estado de
apure frente a la ciudad colombiana de
arauquita algunos migrantes denuncian
que las fuerzas venezolanas incurren en
falsos positivos que dame no me podía
quedar porque lo están matando a uno por
lo menos a unos señores que quedaron
unos vecinos los mataron y le pusieron
unos uniformes del ejército venezolano y
lo hicieron pasar por guerrilleros el
fiscal general de venezuela prometió
investigar las denuncias y sancionar a
los responsables
en colombia el desplazamiento de miles
de venezolanos ha agravado la crisis
humanitaria en los albergues
improvisados en medio de la pandemia de
kobe 19 alrededor de 4000 personas han
estado ya en el municipio hoy recibimos
una
gran afluencia de personas también que
venían desde la victoria estaba puré y
la verdad pues estamos contribuyendo
para que ellos estén aquí con toda
tranquilidad esta semana colombia
expresó su preocupación por la situación
en la frontera e instó a la comunidad
internacional a contribuir con ayuda
para los desplazados por su parte el
ministro de exteriores de venezuela
respondió en twitter rechazando las
declaraciones de la cancillería
colombiana y en un comunicado aseguró
que las operaciones militares se han
hecho contra campamentos ilegales de
grupos armados colombianos venezuela
informó además de la muerte de dos
soldados la detención de un líder de un
grupo armado ilegal y la captura de
otras 32 personas colombia es el
principal destino de los migrantes
venezolanos que huyen de la crisis en
febrero anunció que otorgaría un estatus
de protección de 10 años a cerca de 17
millones de personas del país vecino